- Andy's part of this call?
- I don't have to be.
- [Iris] You're leaving and
then this is like the end.
- Okay cool.
Really?
Okay vlog, weird episode.
I don't even know if we have
a fucking blog, vlog today.
(hip-hop beat)
- Hey.
- How are you?
- Feels good.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to see you.
- Here you go, put this on.
- What's cooking?
- So well I'm a resident here.
It really feels good to be here.
- How long you been here?
- Three months.
- What team are you on?
- So I'm on the influencer team.
Under Kristina and Esmeralda.
Yeah, so I just wanted to basically--
- Stuff and all that?
- Yup.
- How's it going?
- It's going well.
- Where you from?
- Funny story I'm from
Middletown, New York upstate.
It's an like an hour away.
- Yup.
- Yeah so I come here
everyday, wake up at five,
get up, get on a bus, get here at 8:30,
stay here til about 6:00.
- Wanting to be here.
- Yes, 100%.
- How come?
- It's VaynerMedia man.
(laughing)
This is where it's at.
I love the hustle, I love the drive,
this is the future, you know?
Digital content is everything to me.
- Yup.
- I wanna be able to be where--
- The game's gonna be.
- Yes, exactly.
So I wanna be in, eventually
I wanna be able to be like
a creative director or
be like the next you know
Spielberg or something like that.
- Good for you.
You're a creator.
- Yes, I create content.
- Video?
- Yup.
Content, video.
I started doing photography,
funny story, recently
because it's a lot easier
to be able to push content
that is photography.
I'm really busy and trying to hustle,
it's hard for me to mitigate.
- Makes sense, makes sense.
- And I don't wanna put
out low quality stuff
on my Instagram--
- But you know how I think about that?
You gotta be thoughtful.
- Just put everything and document it.
- Just be smart.
Don't overthink it too much.
'Cause that'll hurt you.
If you start thinking
everything's gotta be Spielberg,
you're gonna lose 'cause
that's the next game.
- Right, that's true.
- You're using an old game as a barometer
while you know you wanna
be part of the new game.
- Very true.
- Understand?
- Yeah.
- Keep that in mind.
'Cause that is absolutely
creators' death blow.
You know my content.
- Oh yeah.
- It's what I tell hip-hop kids.
They wanna put out one
song a fuckin' year,
it's not gonna work.
It's what I tell creators like,
the lighting and the sound
doesn't have to be perfect.
- That's true.
- It doesn't.
It did when you have to make
a $500 million dollar movie.
But not a fuckin' Instagram post.
Not one vlog.
- That's true.
- Real pleasure man, I wish you well.
- Thank you.
- Have a great day.
- You too.
- Okay, let me bounce.
Love you, see you, bye.
- Did you wanna go downstairs?
- Yeah I got a call like
what, eight minutes ago?
- Three.
- Cool.
Andy's part of this call?
- I don't have to be.
- [Iris] You're leaving and
then this is like the end.
- Okay, cool.
Really?
Okay vlog, weird episode.
I don't even know, I don't even know if
we have a fuckin' blog, vlog today.
I don't know what to call it.
(laughing)
It's such a shit vlog
that I called it a blog.
Here's what I give a fuck about.
This'll be a nice little short video
that's about to probably
turn into a three minute rant
so stick with me here.
I'm getting weirdly in
tuned to my kindness
and being a good person and caring,
you've seen it on Instagram,
I talked about it in view yesterday.
I'm starting to try to
understand where the new alpha
business leader is gonna
have to really, really settle
into like how nice of a
person are they because
I think it's becoming, and
it's always been weirdly,
but becoming even more
essential to success
which excites the fuck out of me.
Number two, I'm obsessed
with Instagram Stories.
Number three, and the
ads within them, so--
- Search @garyvee on
gifs on Instagram Stories
to see 'em all.
- Ooh, little right hook
from my main man Andy here.
Search on Instagram gifs, search @garyvee.
People are using 'em.
- A lot.
- Like they're really cool.
- Your sniffy sniff one, in
two days has 300,000 views.
- Okay, big right hook, actually let's let
the whole right hook fuck it up.
What do I care about?
I got 4Ds in London.
Motherfuckers 4Ds in London
March 8th, it's gonna be killer.
Voicecon, voicecon.co, May 22nd.
That's gonna be fuckin' important.
We got a sneaker coming,
that's gonna go hard.
We're gonna fuckin' try
to make that a presale,
get fuckin' ready, leave a comment
if you're gonna fuckin' presale that.
- London, Toronto, how
cool how you're doing--
- Oh yeah, I'm doing pop ups
for the Crushing It sneaker.
We only made 600 pairs of these.
They're gonna be fuckin'
$1000 on eBay and StockX,
mark my words.
London, Toronto, London.
So those are gonna be three pop ups.
Is all this information on
garyvaynerchuk.com/events?
Yes, so that's going on.
First In Line.
First In Line's fuckin' gangster.
Our Facebook Messenger,
text messaging platform.
I give away 50 personalized signed books.
A lot of people used it.
This is how I'm gonna give
away stuff all day long.
You're gonna be seeing me
in Wine Country next week.
There's that.
- Saturday the 24th, Wine Library.
- Saturday 24th, Wine Library.
- There's gonna be a lot of people.
- Okay, Saturday 24th there
may not be enough books
so order it on Amazon.
So let's buy more.
Okay, we're at 300?
What do you think it should be, 700?
A lot of people already bought the book.
Wine Library's sitting
with fuckin' Crushing Its.
500?
500, okay so we'll do that.
Make that happen.
What else is happening?
- VaynerSports.
- Yeah, I mean small
businesses that wanna do stuff
with VaynerSports.
We're gonna put up all these URLs like,
Andy you'll help Iris, like
all these different URLs?
'Cause at the forum for VaynerSports,
people that wanna jam.
4Ds man, that's really changing the game.
Businesses are spending $10,000 dollars.
- I think it's crazy that we talked to
in the old company, it's insane.
He doesn't have a Facebook
page on his website
but he is doing everything else.
- If you're doing over a
million dollars a year,
you should come to New York
and or London on March 8th and do a 4Ds.
I'm gonna talk a lot more about selling
and selling is about selling
something you believe in.
I've been very quiet about
VaynerMedia's 4Ds program
'cause it's $10,000
dollars, it's not cheap
for a consulting session day
for me 'cause I come from zero,
but fuckin' watching all
these people make money.
Like the people that went to 4Ds
in fuckin' October,
November, every fuckin' place
I go now like, in Tampa
you saw the guys like,
they're fuckin' making money.
So I don't know, fuck it.
So 4Ds motherfuckers.
And if you are on YouTube
or Facebook watching this,
if you're not following me on Instagram,
that is the fundamental craziest
decision of your career.
It's a massive mistake, it is the funnel.
And by the way, Twitter
is exploding pretty too.
Twitter's getting important.
Like I'm weirdly way
more into Twitter lately.
I'm engaging my, I've
always been smart on Twitter
but like I feel like I'm really in it.
I feel like a lot of
people, you know what it is?
Actually, can we throw some right hook?
- You've always been in
it but it's more content,
I would say.
- Seth, where's your audio content?
Like I want these audio videos
that you and fuckin' Calvin
and Caesar and all you fuckin'
characters promised me.
Fuck Caesar, like let's go,
let's make 'em everyday, let's go.
So I'm excited about that,
very excited about the podcast.
If you're not following my podcast,
it's like you're not
subscribed to my podcast,
that is a fundamental
crazy thing in your life.
First In Line, First In
Line's gonna be the big one.
Like if you don't know
what First In Line is,
it's my messenger, just
message me on Facebook
and it automatically replies.
If you just message me
on Facebook right now,
it automatically replies.
Anyway, lots going on.
Just call this the fuckin'
biz dev episode, perfect.
What else do we fuckin' want people to do?
Buy the book, if don't you have the book,
it's fundamentally the craziest thing
you're doing in your life.
- Would you do first IG?
- What about, what about, Seth,
are we being serious
about, I don't feel like
we're being serious enough
about my Alexa skill.
Are we?
- Probably not serious enough.
- We're not promoting it.
And we're not producing original content,
we're using other content.
So let's make that fix, okay.
If you're not following me on Snapchat,
it's a huge mistake 'cause I'm
getting more serious again.
What are you feeling?
- Team GaryVee Instagram,
Spotify playlist.
- Ooh, the Monday to
Monday Spotify playlist.
If you have Spotify and
you've not subscribed
to the Monday to Monday playlist,
it's one of the craziest
fundamental things
you're making a mistake on in your life.
Oh the Wine Club, I haven't thrown--
- I've been enjoying the Wine Club.
- Wait til you fuckin' see.
Everyone's getting February right now.
March is fuckin', if you
just want to one off,
if you wanna sign up for
the Wine Club for one month,
make it for March.
By the way, Iris, I want
this edited really funny
like all the URLs below
but like also like--
- [Iris] Yeah, yeah, yeah
all the graphics in there.
- The Wine Club is gonna be ridic,
I think it's $160 worth
of wine for, what is it?
- $55.
- $55 delivered, no shipping?
- No shipping.
- I'm gonna put my dad out of business.
Literally, we're getting hammered.
Anyway, love you guys, see ya.
(upbeat ambient music)